working with biological data i think
it's some of the most interesting things
you can do in uh with machine learning
these days it's um
the data scale is huge
the applications are are amazing it's
very high dimensional
uh it's uh and there's like so many sort
of features of you know about like
working with biological data that you
just can't um
have somewhere else welcome to 20 minute
leaders
just sit back relax and learn from the
leaders of today
it's a journey each one is different
unique inspiring
let's get started
[Music]
this episode is powered by j ventures a
community driven vc found in silicon
valley
in partnership with lomitek and
sponsored by hippo insurance
touring opposed labs and hillel stanford
i rarely get
truly inspired by a startup or a company
or a mission but this company is
unlike any other i've met when i walk
into their offices
i see some of the brightest people i've
ever met in my life and when i think
about the challenge they're trying to
solve
i get truly excited and inspired meet
louis volch
chief technology officer and co-founder
of immuni
louis f warlock is the chief technology
officer and co-founder at immuni
where he is helping bring
transformational change to immunology
cancer science and beyond muni has a
team of over 60 experts in machine
learning software immunology and
genomics technologies
and are focused on mapping and
reprogramming the immune system
which has allowed his team to build the
largest database for immunological data
in the world
previously warlock was the head of data
science and machine learning at israel
tech challenge
and worked on a variety of genomics and
ai effort industries
including volunteer and at mit louis
volo
welcome to 20 minute leaders we're in
the beautiful tel aviv
in the balcony of your offices you've
built an empire
i've gotten to be in this office about a
year ago
and it while it looks the same you can
feel that it's different you feel how
you've grown tremendously
how you're literally changing the world
and you know that
if i even begin to describe what you're
doing with immunize
i wouldn't be able to stop and i would
catch myself in a hurdle because it's
just
too complicated and too awesome but you
know the the way that you look at
computational biology
in 2021 with with machine learning
advancements
bringing together the most incredible
people in the world and in israel
to work on this project with you is
inspiring to me but before we get to
that tell me a little bit about yourself
how do you
you know grow up as an engineer as an
entrepreneur and what sort of frames
your mindset
as you go through your journey yeah and
thank you for doing the the interview as
well as although all of them i really
enjoy
them in general so i i grew up in brazil
originally so in rio de janeiro
and i lived there until i was 16 and i
think a lot of what i did in my
childhood was a mix of basketball with
math
and then i used to have this um linear
regression that i kept a track off of
how tall i was supposed to be if i kept
growing linearly
and i was supposed to be 2 meters and
13. wow
and turned out that my my projections
was wrong
which made me gave up basketball and not
math which is awesome
and so it's like i stuck with math and
then
i moved to the us and i went to mit for
my
first degree and second degree as well
as
i started a phd which i took a break off
in which i'm still in that break
and uh well i've always been very
interested in math
science computer science as well as how
it relates to them to the world
right and um and i think those are my my
core passions
so as you go through your academic
career
you know pre-college mit what what is it
about math
that that gets you going it's not it's
not something that
most people in the world understand i
think that i do share a similar
passion that you do but what is it about
the subject
and about the work that you're doing
within the mathematical context
that just really excites you yeah i
think what i always liked about
math is that it sort of like forced me
to be
thorough i think that's the there's sort
of like no
way around there's just no way around it
there is no
hand waving there is no um there is
that's really the only way it's for you
to deeply understand things and
think about things like extremely
critically and in a structured way
right and then that's the only way that
things move forward
and i think that's one of the things
that really uh attracted me to
yes to math and it's um
and you know comparing with
entrepreneurship it's
it's different in the sense that
entrepreneurship you do need to make
you know both decisions that are um that
are not you know necessarily like fully
put
right honestly but i think um kind of
culturally
sort of shaped how um how are you
thinking just trying to be as thorough
as possible
right i remember going back all the way
to high school one of my favorite math
teachers was all about proving
everything we learned you know i think
some teachers enjoy going through the
textbook and saying these are the axioms
that you should know
and but then i had this one teacher who
would just feel the need
to prove everything he taught us and it
i
i i feel like i'm looking at everything
else in life in the same way that you
know you're making a speculation even as
an entrepreneur
you have to prove in some you know
coherent way
why this will make sense and then prove
it in three other ways and show how
exciting it is that you're converging
to this sort of like one thought process
and i think that that's also a good
reason why a lot of mathematicians are
great entrepreneurs
and so you're at mit you're starting
your phd
and there's this guy nam solomon and
you're partnering together to solve
you know maybe you know arguably one of
the most important problems that one
could solve
where we are today and so how do you
meet and what are you aiming for yeah so
one of the things that i bonded very
quickly with no
one was exactly around math and unlike
me who
dropped out of a math career he actually
succeeded in it uh
for a while and he's an amazing
mathematician so i think a lot of the
early
bonding we had was around that and just
like this kind of like similar way of
of seeing the world and i remember just
sort of you know amazed me from the
beginning and in that sense and i think
another part that very much
that we shared very much was part of i
think what i described before is that
like i think
we're both you know thorough but at the
same time we don't have like a major
impact
yeah in the world and a lot of what we
were thinking was you know how to take
some of these
in theories and applications in machine
learning that we were you know very much
like a part of
uh and have the broadest possible impact
and uh and very early on we started to
understand that we wanted uh you know to
have the broadest possible impact
uh we wanted something that you know we
would make that we had a competitive
advantage on
and also something that really helped
improve uh
lives and a lot of people say that
but most people don't actually mean it
you're literally improving lives you're
literally talking about
ourselves our biology yeah it's not just
a buzzword right
yeah and that's the decision we made
very early on so and you know we're
thinking that maybe in the first like
week or so we were considering you know
working on things that
didn't have to do with biology and then
very early on we made that decision of
working and with biological data
and um you know as a quick like plug for
all kinds of machine learning uh people
out there
and working with biological data i think
it's some of the most interesting things
you can do in uh with machine learning
these days it's um
the data scale is huge
uh the applications are are amazing it's
very high dimensional
uh it's uh and there's like so many sort
of features of you know about like
working with biological data that you
just can't um
have somewhere else and um and i think a
lot of what the
bone what builds us as a company is this
um
this this um you know thesis in a way
that you know really
the intersection of machine learning and
biology is the future and we want to you
know be one of the first companies are
like you know
really helping push that forward i love
it i you know what i love doing through
the show
is hearing about companies and hearing
about you know there's so many decisions
that
that as entrepreneurs are making you
know not just financial decisions or
product decisions but also hiring and
culture and how you're building it
one of the things that you know forever
i'll be completely inspired by what
you're doing is
simply you know walking around the
offices and seeing the team and seeing
the team that you chose to surround
yourself with
can you share with me a few statistics
on the team you know the types of people
that you're hiring they're
like with their backgrounds and what are
the types of people that have joined
immuni
over the past year or so yeah and i
think it's
it's one of the things we're definitely
the most proud of it's you know it's
crazy yeah
so i'll say some statistics about the
software team so they are
about half uh graduates which is the
most it's the most elite comprehensive
program you can do in the army
which consists of i believe a master's
degree right and
and placement in some of the most elite
places most confidential places in the
army
yeah and they said they are like
credible and the other ones are also
like ex
google and pollen and places like that
in our computational biology team we
have um
i think about like two-thirds are phds
or post-docs from
from either berkeley stanford the
weizmann institute mit or harvard
and um and we in our lab team it's
essentially
the same kind of uh background in terms
of like immunology and genomics
but one of the crucial things for us in
terms of hiring it's not just bringing
people that are excellent in their
respective fields
but are people that deeply share
this commitment to being
multi-disciplinary so you know our
software developers for example like we
for us it's not enough to bring someone
who's just you know the best software
developer
we want you know the best software
developers but also
that really want to learn about biology
and about immunology and about
everything else that we are doing and
having this um
habit of going so out of your comfort
zone uh in terms of learning and in
terms of like collaboration
is one of the most important things and
i think that's the one of the main
cultural
i would say aspects of me and i are sort
of all these people that are really the
best
in their respective areas but they're
just so interested in everything else
that's going on and they want to learn
and they want to collaborate
that's very special for us what is it
like leading a team like this
you're leading people that are each used
to being the the best in the room
whether it's in any of the institutions
you mentioned or any of the companies
you know
every literally every person you would
meet here are people that you know
they have their own ground they have
their own context their own passions
their own thought processes
how it must be different leadership than
you know in a general team that you
would that you would find
did you find any difference do you feel
any difference
yeah and um so first it's really an
i think an honor right in a way to to be
working with
uh with this team i think you know
starting a company and
being an entrepreneur is a hard thing in
general
and there's like the business challenges
there are um
there's all kinds of jobs into the list
them and uh we just
really have this honor of having this
very nice first of all like
and collaborative and very talented team
that just kind of like solves one of the
the problems right we don't have like
many people issues everyone is very
collaborative and nice and
and leading a team like that uh you know
my definition is essentially
just helping set the context yeah
for what we are doing uh and just making
sure that the thing dynamics are right
and essentially letting them run the
show
that's the that's i think that you know
my definition our definition of uh
of management here you know we're right
here to uh dictate details of
what to do we're here to help inspire to
help
set the the broader context to help
everyone like figure out you know
what are like what is where the higher
level goals that we are doing
but we want as many of the decisions
being taken in the company not to be
taken by me or by my co-founder or by
right or base or like the the usual
people that would be taken
we want as many of the decisions to be
taken by the people like that are like
doing the work
sure and as many of the new ideas to to
come from them and
we're just trying to set like a
framework in which all of that can
happen right
and that's much more powerful you know
having 50 amazing people
coming up with ideas and making
decisions is much more powerful than
having
three i mean i think also the big
difference here every single person in
the team would be a prime candidate for
an investor to invest in them as
entrepreneurs themselves right these are
the top people
that you would you would trust them to
build whatever products they would build
so you're literally taking you know you
know dozens of entrepreneurs putting
them together on this mission
and then and i love the perspective of
empowering them and but also being very
dynamic and knowing how do you empower
different types of people because some
do need more structured approach some do
need
less structured approach so you know
last month you announced
the 60 million dollar raise for the
current round by some of the top
investors
uh that i can think of and some of them
have been on the show as well which
and and we spoke specifically about
immunized and
you know the the path that you're going
on and then you know even the problem
that you're trying to solve
which is the idea and what i loved when
i read about what you're doing
you know now in the context of this
phrase which is this transition from
first you know mapping
our immune system and the single cell
biology within our bodies and
understanding you know what exists
but then being able to take that a step
further and saying how can we now build
on top of that and discover drugs and
discover
you know different implications that we
couldn't have even thought of before
because we didn't have this
visibility layer as to what's happening
so that was the dumbest way that i could
explain it to myself
can you give me a brief rundown of what
are you actually what problem are you
solving here
and and why is this the best time to do
it because i do believe this is a crazy
time to be doing this
in a good way so what is the muni yeah
so one of the
uh the methodologies in machine learning
that you know
and i really wanted to make it into
reality in
immunology as well as concept of
transfer learning and this allows you to
take
learnings in one problem and transfer
them systematically you know as
the data and as models to another
problem so for example
in learning how to differentiate between
cats and dogs that's like one of these
canonical problems computer vision
you can learn for example about shapes
and about textures and about colors
there
and leverage that to apply to different
problems how to differentiate between
tables and chairs in a way and
one of the things that we are doing in
immuno is doing that for the immune
system
in a way so the immune system is a
central player driving
all kinds of defense against diseases as
well as some diseases themselves
and there's all these commonalities in
how the immune system is supposed to be
defending
you against lung cancer against bladder
cancer
and how it can be leveraged to to fight
these cancers and how
um and the complement of that is
autoimmunity right where your immune
system is too strong
as well as like aging related diseases
and the point is that there's a lot in
common
across all of them there are all these
cell types that are playing a role there
are pathways that are doing similar
things across all of them
and immunize the company seeing that
from the top of the tree
in a way where we can take these
learnings from lung cancer or from
bladder cancer and transfer them to
melanoma
and and seeing that you know from top of
the tree in a way allows us to see all
of them
right better and uh and you know as i
mentioned with our fundraising
what one of the things we're doing now
is trying to develop the next generation
of therapeutics that makes
that leverages that right and allows us
to fight
and how does that tangibly work do you
just work with pharmaceutical companies
on the whole drug
discovery process either by running
simulations or or figuring out even how
to prioritize the experiments
how does the actual you know there's one
thing to come and do these a lot of
these models you know theoretically
within the office in tel aviv
but then there's these huge pharma
companies in the us that are actually
going and they need to deploy this
knowledge
that you're you know you're discovering
that just the world doesn't know about
it yet
so how does this actually get translated
into you know real world circumstances
and
impact that could potentially now reach
a billion people yeah
uh so the the way this works is that we
partner with specific pharma companies
on specific drugs or disease areas
so for example we might have a
partnership on the immune components of
diabetes
with a specific pharma company for their
drug and we help them
improve their drug or we might help them
combine
different drugs that they have into um
something that works better combined
right and so we try to do in in that way
where we would partner with pharma
companies
to help improve their specific
therapeutic program or come up with uh
with new drugs
and then we share some of the economics
downstream of that right so it's
essentially like a partnership and we
get
any benefits in their own way so let's
let's play a game five years down the
line uh
we're obviously sitting in a little bit
of a bigger office hopefully the same
beautiful view behind us hopefully with
you here as well i would
honor my honor but uh where are we what
is the world like how has
how has immunized changed the way that i
live my life
in five ten years time so i would say in
um in that it will be much clearer
how your immune system is keeping
you um young it's keeping you healthy
sounds important and uh and that
essentially i think we would like um
not just to be better drugs for diseases
but that
everyone understands that the immune
system is the core of their health
and that it's really what's keeping you
uh young and healthy and
free from disease so our visions extends
from
building better drugs for cancer to
autoimmune diseases
all the way into aging related diseases
and
the most important things keeping people
healthy right and um
and i think we want team unite to be the
company that's sort of like you know
helping
with this entire puzzle together uh and
you know helping uh seek people helping
healthy people
uh live better lives one of the things
that noam wrote on the techcrunch
article he wrote that we have this
that we immunize has this unique
privilege
to move slow when when needed or or
better wording is you know not have the
pressure
the economical pressure of the world to
move as fast as you know we have to
reach arr
of this by this year and this hockey
stick you're solving a real problem
you're solving
deep technology problem that you know
takes years to do
but at the end i think you know i
couldn't think of something more
exciting to work on than something that
you know could take years but you know
that it's so meaningful and it's so
proprietary
that if your team doesn't do it then
there might not be another team that is
able to do it that you really
are you know bringing together the best
people in the world to solve one of the
most challenging problems in the world
and from the few people that i got to
meet here i i'm completely inspired by
these types of films and
if i look at the type of entrepreneur
that i want to be i'm looking at you
guys as
you know as a model for me uh i don't
know if it fits you know the typical
what a typical entrepreneurial journey
that people are excited about but
but this is the type of thing that is
literally transforming the world and so
uh thank you very much for all the work
thank you for coming here right 20
minutes go by way too fast
but i have the most important question
for you which is three words that you
would choose to describe yourself
three words let's say um
open
bold and
interested i love it thank you so so
much for
for joining me here thanks this is
beautiful and you
hopefully you'll see me around here
because i'm just going to keep coming in
and harassing you guys so thank you very
[Music]
much
you